NARRATOR: Five years ago,
Julie and Andrew Puckett
were working in the
theater industry in Chicago
when they realized that
working in the theater industry
just wasn't providing
them with the salaries
they needed to live in Chicago.
JULIE PUCKETT:
The cost of living
was so high that
Andrew and I both had
to work about 60 hours a week
to sort of pay the bills.
NARRATOR: Even though
Julie and Andrew
both took on multiple
side jobs, they still
weren't feeling any relief.
JULIE PUCKETT: It was
like, we're so young
and we're wasting all of the
best years of our life cooped
up in an office.
So we decided to look into
alternative living situations,
where we wouldn't be beholden to
a landlord or neck deep in rent
or a mortgage or
anything like that.
We found this bus.
It was not really our cup
of tea aesthetic-wise,
but it was $9000.
And so we were like, we
could definitely afford that.
We got all of our savings,
which was $10,000.
That's all we had, literally,
all we had in the whole world.
The bus is 30 feet long.
It is seven feet wide, so it's
around the 200 square feet-ish.
We got rid of all
of our furniture,
literally every
piece of furniture.
I don't think we kept anything.
It just wasn't practical.
NARRATOR: The couple
spent four months
renovating and building custom
furniture for their new home.
JULIE PUCKETT: For
electricity and water,
we both have external hookups
like an RV-style hookup.
We have a sink.
We have a shower.
It's pretty typical.
I think people are
usually really surprised.
They're like, you have
shower in your bus?
Yes, I live in it.
NARRATOR: While wages in the US
have largely remained stagnant,
the cost of basic necessities
such as food, gas, and housing
have been increasing leading
more and more young people
to seek out creative,
affordable, living solutions.
Just search a van life
or tiny home on Instagram
and you'll find growing
communities in search
of a simpler way of life.
JULIE PUCKETT: The transition
was really hard at first.
For the first six
months, adjusting
to being in this tight
residence with another person,
you're just like, you're
in my space all the time.
I'm very controlling about that
this has to be done this way,
and this has to
be done this way.
And you wipe off the
counter when you're done.
But you can't be like that here,
because you'll just go crazy.
So you just have to
kind of be a lot more
accommodating to each
other and understanding.
NARRATOR: Julie and Andrew
settled into a campground space
at Stone Mountain
Park in Georgia.
Because Andrew also
works at the state park,
they get a reduced rate
to rent a campsite.
JULIE PUCKETT: We live
right next to the lake,
and the mountains
are right there.
All of these hiking,
outdoor nature trails,
it sort of fulfills this amazing
thing in us where we're like,
this is what we needed.
We don't have to work as
much, because we don't have
to pay so much
money towards rent
and all these other
things, which is amazing.
So we've gotten to really
focus on our personal goals,
our career goals,
our relationship
as a married couple.
It's really great.
And I think that is
what I would definitely
offer to people
whenever they're like,
why would you guys
want to do that?
I say, there's so
much more to life
than just paying for stuff.
And if you can take
some of that time
that you would put
towards working
and put it towards stuff that
really needs your attention,
so many good things
will come from that.
NARRATOR: From living in a
bus to living on a tiny boat,
watch this next episode
about Louis Bird
as he rowed from California
to Hawaii to reconnect
with the memory of his father.